ladies and gentlemen i'm gonna quote the
joker right now
it's all part of the plan i'm calling
[ __ ] i'm a man zach snyder
right here today call him bs okay let me
again
let me get the disclaimers all out of
the way i'm a very big champion of the
snyder cut i'm
very excited for it remember when
everyone was like oh and that's not our
code's never going to come
out oh no a lot of us had faith that one
day would have been zack snyder
doubted it for a while good amount of
time and now look where he is today
i like the bvs ultimate edition and if
you saw a rank of the dcu films
man of steel's on our top three this is
by no means a
jab at zack snyder i actually think what
he's doing is really smart let's break
it down people so recently
snyder himself said he has no plans to
continue his dceu
after the snyder cut comes out on hbo
max here's the full quote he was not
calling book debate he said look
i never thought i'd be here doing this i
didn't think i'd be finishing justice
league
the truth is and it's been widely
reported and i have no issue this is an
old movie this is a
years old movie i'm working on the dc
universe has gone and branched off and
done its own thing and that's fine
is it is it zachary as far as what i did
and as far as what my vision for what i
wanted to do with these characters and
the journey i wanted them to go on
it's well known that i planned on more
movies five movies or something
it's kind of like an ambiguous plan but
i'm busy i've got a lot going on
i mean yeah in the middle of assembling
the snyder cut he's also been doing his
netflix zombie movie as well
is it cool that the fans have so much
faith in the trajectory yes it's amazing
and i couldn't be happier and i'm
excited for them to see justice league
so they can really drink
the entire elixir of justice league what
a good word elixir
but would i continue i have no plan to
but like i said i didn't think i'd be
here
so who knows there it is who knows you
think you need to know
you clever dog i'm so proud of the way
you're doing this
this is just reminding me of the
spider-man situation all over again
what we call public negotiations
i think zack snyder is in the ultimate
position ever since this pandemic with
the movie industry we've all been
twiddling our thumbs going which
which streaming thing is really going to
be the ultimate game changer and it
looks like the answer is going to be an
hbo max right when wonder woman 1984
dropped there people were like game
changer and then they announced all the
movies
game changer i really think for dc
moving forward it's going to be the
snyder cut it's very apparent that they
don't only pay attention to box office
success they also pay attention to
critical and audience reception as well
depending on if i think already the
subscriptions are secured
for snyder cut but i think on audience
and critical reception
if that is good this is just the perfect
opportune time for zack snyder once that
comes out and if it's received
well for him to negotiate so that way he
can have the
ultimate creative freedom moving forward
we all know
zack snyder's at his best when he's able
to have his creative freedom his
director cuts
99 of the time are better than the
theatrical cuts and if the snyder cup
proves
to be like oh yeah people really love
this that's just gonna give him the
leeway
to open up the negotiation doors for
okay but if i do this
more money and full creative control
that is what i think he's doing right
here it's like those spider-man deals
you know
it's all public negotiations he knows
what he's doing att is the one running
the warner brothers ship at the end of
the day now
oh god and i can only imagine he'd
probably would rather be working with
the hbo wing of that than the wb
wing of that not that they are too
separate but i have to imagine that in
the
theatrical world where they still want
to put movies out that way it would
probably be a lot harder for him to
secure that amount of control
i feel like hbo max 2 would make a great
opportunity to separate the universes
because they clearly have certain things
that are going in their movie world that
could perhaps and he's used the phrase
elseworlds
to describe certain issues with wonder
woman 1984 and diana and certain issues
of that and so i feel like especially if
they're gonna keep you know this
diana prince in the movie sphere it
makes a lot of sense to have him
continue in a more tv
oriented or episodic format where he can
dig into his
deep gritty dark thematic material that
he loves to cover so much
and then he can bring his decapitating
wonder woman absolutely into his snyder
versus wearing a necklace of heads
i'd love to see that version i think
that'd be really cool let's see that
brought to us be awesome
it'd be awesome i know there's been a
back and forth on the internet hey is
this wonder woman
this seems to be totally out of
character it looks cool but out of
character but as a lot of people have
come to the forefront and talking about
that wonder woman image there's
variations of the comic i feel like
usually it's elseworld versions of
wonder woman
where she's you know someone who's
ruthless decapitates people but there's
other versions
as well where she's not unlikely to
decapitate ahead here or there
yeah i'd love to see that version
brought to life and clearly that was
part of his original planning gal gadot
seemed game to do it
she did the photos oh yeah although to
be fair i mean on the most recent movie
and she's a producer on that they
partly opted to take like the sword and
shield out because they thought that
would be a bit too
on the aggressive side so i've been
curious about what her stance
specifically is on these things because
i get a good sense for how patty jenkins
feels so yeah guys to sum it up dcu
as we've all come to experience it's all
trial and error the way these guys work
whatever works they keep it going what
doesn't work they scrap it and that's
actually a big part of
why i really like the dc eu some people
will say that's
part of the flaw within its system for
me i feel like the dceu
is what's cool about it especially now
is how
wildly different their films are the
variations of them i think are really
neat
some of them are just okay to me a
couple i don't like and then there's a
and then a good handful i really do love
at the end of the day i like the
creative integrity of
really mixing it up
but anywho is ray fisher fired let's
talk about that a little bit
yeah is it gonna be recast for the flash
here's what's happening here ray fisher
supposedly was never supposed to even be
in flashpoint
uh mark hughes he tweeted out the rumors
of cyborg recasting are a lie
cyborg is not in the flash and the role
is not being recast i've confirmed this
with the studio
the rumor is false okay all right i can
get on board with that
but guys look let's face facts here when
it comes to the dceu films
ray fisher's gone he's out undoubtedly
he's gone
walter hamada just renewed his contract
a multi-year contract
very recently ray fisher said walter
hamada is the most dangerous kind of
enabler his lies and wb
prs failed september 4th hit piece
sought to undermine the very real issue
of the justice league investigation
i will not participate in any production
associated with him so when he's going
out there saying that
insulting the head the boss the main guy
to answer to when it comes to playing
cyborg he's out he's gone
it seems to be the only way to do it
because at this point they're not gonna
sit around and smile while you know zack
snyder brings him on for ten more movies
or something like that if that were to
happen
and i'm not even talking from a place of
do i side with ray fisher or do i side
with wb
and how they've been handling the whole
ray fisher case i'm not talking about
that i'm just talking about the fact
that
dude you insulted the head guy who just
got a multi-year contract deal and today
he's more valuable right now for dc than
you are
i think ray fisher's gonna be gone but
here's the other side of the equation
here i believe it was walter hamada who
did say in the new york times article it
was like a wb studio executive
a dc i i believe it might have been
walter hamado feel free to correct me
the snyder cut
is a narrative called the sack it's a
dead end that leads nowhere
so basically implying that there's no
path forward with it that should be the
end-all be-all just let it be this
one-time event that's his take on it him
being the head of dc films it's like all
right i guess that's it after the snyder
cut that might even lead more people to
go
yeah that makes more sense why zack
snyder doesn't have any more plans going
forward like he's just gonna can those
additional movie ideas that he had with
the momentum he's garnered
from the snyder cut it just doesn't make
sense for him to not do it like i said
earlier att is the one who's really
calling the shots right now it's very
apparent here we just look at what
happened with hbo max and the
crazy uproars that happened there it's
clearly a t's call
they're the ones in charge and if snyder
cut proves to be a success
maybe we won't see cyborg appear in any
of the dc eu
films but in the subsidiary category of
the snyder verse
is where i think cyborg ray fisher's
legacy can still carry on
because he might not have to talk to mr
walter hamada he could just
work directly through zack snyder who
clearly loves ray fisher
that's the big thing that makes me quite
curious about how this constellation
fits together because it seems like it
would cause
problems for zack snyder to have you
know this whole ray fisher
situation not resolved in any way and i
mean
while i could see that being a bridge
like him working through zack snyder
it's still associated with walter hamada
and so i don't know
how that would actually fit into ray
fisher's philosophy thus far of
accountability over entertainment
because
you know i mean he's the head yeah how
you can't really escape him because
even if you're just at hbo you're still
wb you're still a t
i would be very surprised if ray fisher
gets to continue at all
although i mean i i can definitely see
what you're saying with zack snyder i
mean even if he doesn't have an exact
plan for what follows the snyder cut
if that's something like with all this
debate about you know people filmmakers
up in arms about
i don't want my movie released on hbo
max and whatnot you know they could
probably see
an opportunity to increase a streaming
only piece of content through zack
snyder and maybe he comes up with
something else or something more
contained or whatever
yeah i i don't see how ray fisher
continues of his own accord
or anyone else's really because it's
just gonna be more problems
and more distraction more controversy
the more they have his face in there
perhaps perhaps but i think when
schneiderka comes out and they see that
cyborg really is the heart of that
snyder cut movie i think
people are gonna want more of him true
anything can have anything can happen i
think it's subject to change
guys what do you think do you believe
zack snyder
do you think cyborg ray fisher is
officially out or do you think he will
have a future continuing in the snyder
vs films leave your thoughts down below
subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
we'll catch you guys soon